alright this this next clip is hilarious
and it's so revealing I want to pull up
the tweet first by mrs. Betty Bowers
because everyone's talking about it
about this but she put this perfectly
and this is what she said quote this
hilarious too candid guy behind Trump
was deemed an unsuitable background prop
by the Trump choreographers he was
replaced with someone who could actually
feign enthusiasm for Dear Leader
alright let's take a look at the video
to find things out that we didn't know
it's hard and harder to win then popular
popular Lord you go to three or four
states and boom boom boom you win the
fights like the hundred-yard dash versus
running the mile you practice
differently I mean this expressions okay
well you know let's be clear he's there
to support Donald Trump so it very
likely this guy is a tool but I mean
everybody every dog has its day like
that's the only appropriate response
that you could have to Donald Trump all
right let me repeat that is the only
earth appropriate Trump - Donald Trump's
madness everyone sitting behind him
constantly cheering they're like
completely programmed automatons
sycophants you know they're just there
to cheer it anything he says and this
guy can't believe he's like oh all right
so that was unacceptable clearly it's
not acceptable you can't have anybody
with natural reactions standing behind
you and so here's a video of him being
replaced as the president speaks and
they escort him out he's like whatever
I'm gone I mean this is this is classic
I know I think we all know that these
events are staged no matter who no
matter what but how often do you get
such such a confluence of insanity where
you have the madman in chief on stage
saying some ridiculous dribble that's so
ridiculous that somebody who came there
support him literally cannot believe how
stupid this man is talking in front of
them and then you get the obvious switch
changing of the guard so you know you
have people in the background clearly I
mean I would do this to you you're
looking at the screen how does it look
what's the image so just it's not to
knock these science in the art form of
stagecraft right because I'd be
disingenuous if I didn't say everything
around me was at least partially staged
you know what I mean because you know
because you want your set to look as
good as you can look for your budget and
for your diaphragm Donald Trump pays
good money and I guess they're saying
they're not you know we're not gonna pay
this guy his $50 to stand behind Donald
Trump but he actually responds naturally
to the president I mean now I don't want
to keep drawing this false equivalence
either let's shift gears you know when
Barack Obama speaks he says some good
stuff he genuinely says stuff that
people are gonna cheer for I don't think
you're ever going to get a single video
of president I mean well I was gonna say
george w bush too but i have to pause
and remember just how ignorant george w
bush really was let's take a moment of
silence for this not being the first
idiotic republican president that we've
had to suffer so in my excitement to to
make this look as though donald trump
was the dumbest president we've ever had
just go back one administration go back
skip obama and go to george HW but
george w bush and we've had we've had
our encounter with ignorant presidents
before so to my point you are not going
to find a video of someone having a
naturally negative response to barack
obama because barack obama really didn't
say anything in his speeches that could
ever lead to that kind of reaction now
some of the things he may have done in
office is a different question but
that's not what we're discussing here
these people know full well who they're
dealing with
that's the point of this clip
republicans know that they are dealing
with a [ __ ] as president of the united
states they knew
W Bush was a [ __ ] and still AM or run
today and we should not rehabilitate him
I don't care how many pieces of candy he
passes Michelle Obama he's a [ __ ] who
destroyed the Middle East destabilized
it and count and and threw us into a
generation long war and he's a [ __ ]
they knew who he was they knew exactly
that the last redeeming you know
partially redeemable Republican
president that we had was Herbert Walker
Bush and that's only because the
situation's Ronald Reagan left them was
so bad that he had no choice but to
raise taxes to try to actually fix the
economy but I digress the point is the
two Republican presidents after that
have been on I mean magnitudes of order
more ignorant than anything that we've
seen in a long time so much so that
people who support him have to be at
home have to be at these rallies like
who in the what in the entire what
that's the only natural response to
Donald Trump that that's it but if I was
actually try to say something meaningful
in this clip because it's Friday and I
ready to I'm getting ready to go thanks
for having me David but uh I'm ready to
go to a happy hour somewhere but
something meaningful to be taken from
this clip is that they embrace this
ignorant they 100% embrace this level of
ignorance and it has become a tool that
they use I talked about it earlier this
week weaponized ignorant it is a tool
that they use for political power and so
it is fun to really laughs and how
ignorant Donald Trump is and how
ignorant George W Bush was and is but
the reality of it is is that they
understand the art form of ignorance and
they have weaponized it to a point that
they can gain political power by being
the dumbest person in the room what does
that say about America says a lot of
terrible things about America but and it
certainly does not bode well for our
future but like I said before if they
can weaponize ignorance and hatred and
bigotry and if they can be willing to
break all of the rules in order to do
the wrong thing surely we on the Left
must be willing to weaponize the truth
weaponize all of our intellect and not
just sit on it and not just navel
and talk about how smart we are but
weaponize it and break all of the rules
to do the right thing listen folks it's
been a great week thanks for hanging out
with me David thanks so much for your
for the opportunity all of you go over
to my page YouTube and subscribe and if
you don't subscribe there or even if you
do go to the Benjamin Nixon show comm
and sign up for my newsletter I will not
I do not spam I might hit you with one
or two emails a week at most and I give
you a succinct breakdown of what's
happening in three bullet points the
point of it is to get to the point so
that you can get everything that you
need to know before you get bored that's
the point thanks again have a great week
everyone weekend and I will see you
sometime in October take care
today's program sponsored in part by
blinkers comm slash Pakman I've talked
about blinkers before it's this awesome
app that I've been using for several
months now and what it does is take the
best and most critically acclaimed
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks that you can
listen to in one sitting you could
listen to ten books in an afternoon I
know that many in our audience want to
expand their horizons and learn more
about all sorts of different topics but
we're mostly limited by time to some
degree I know I'm not able to read all
of the books that I want simply because
I've got other stuff going on and that's
why blink is - such a great tool you can
absorb the most important information
and insights from the book in one
sitting and our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube click the link in the video
description and after that free trial if
you like blinka stand I think you are
going to like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to be li NK is t.com slash PA k ma n